hello
my name is dennis allison i'm organizing
and uh
curating the uh stanford university
uh computer systems colloquium
ee 380. this talk was
presented in spring 2020
for that colloquium our speaker today is
francois holm he is at facebook research
in paris
and is going to explain to us the use of
deep learning for symbolic mathematics
francois welcome thank you
hello so i'm francois i'm a researcher
in facebook ai research in paris
and i'm going to present a paper that
was written with guillaume lamp also
from facebook
ai research in paris titled deep
learning for
symbolic mathematics so
in a few words what are we doing
we are investigating the possible use of
natural language processing techniques
deep learning
natural language processing on problems
of mathematics
such as integration and differential
equations
and using this we have tried to we have
trained neural networks
over generated data sets so data sets of
problems and
solutions that we created and we managed
to achieve state-of-the-art performance
meaning by that that
we can do better that the big
commercial tools such as or from
mathematica or maple
on our test sets so this is more or less
what we did and what i'm going to
present
um our original paper was submitted to
the international conference on learning
and representation iclear
last september it was accepted in
november i think
with a with the spotlight the conference
will be held virtually because of the
situation at the end of the month
and there's an improvation of the paper
on archive
soon on ikea papers and the code and
data sets
are all open and accessible on github
on the facebook research github
so what's the starting point of our
research where did we come from
it starts with a reflection on the
success the current success
of neural networks neural networks are
extremely good
they've progressed a lot and they've
become state of the art on a very wide
range of problems
in particular they're extremely
efficient when doing pattern recognition
you know no matter it is
finding objects in images recognizing a
face or recognizing the speaker
or cutting and recording with many
people in several different voices
they're very good at that on the other
hand they have their limits and they
so far they had limited success in
everything related to symbolic
computation so that's
using symbols and assembling them or
manipulating
them so as to do computation for
instance in mathematics
it's been tried to have neural networks
do computation and
they tend to fail sometimes quite
miserably
on very simple tasks like integer
multiplication integer multiplication
well they can manage base two but then
it's not symbolic because you just have
two symbols
and they can manage short integers but
actually as soon as the length
gets a bit large it doesn't work anymore
and this is strange we thought because
on the on the one hand one would be like
one would be tempted to say okay
neural networks are not good at symbolic
manipulation but on the other hand
they are extremely efficient in natural
language processing and in machine
translation
and these are totally simple
manipulation tasks so
we started with this apparent
contradiction between the fact that
neural nets work very well for language
at symbolic manipulation and badly
at math for the same symbolic
manipulation
so the original intuition was
when you look at the current
architectures that work in machine
translation
how do they proceed well the first thing
is that they work
at the sentence level and they consider
a sentence
as a basic sequence of tokens those
models are called
sequence to sequence they transform a
sequence to another sequence sect to sec
and when i'm saying it's sequence
consider a sequence of tokens it means
that
you will not um represent the sentence
as a pass tree
you will not represent the words as
verbs or none etc
or anything they're just a sequence of
stuff of tokens and this is what the
machine
or at least deep nets seem to prefer
the second thing is that they don't seem
to care
at all about domain specific knowledge
you don't need to tell them about
grammar about dictionaries about all
that
they don't need when they translate for
instance dictionaries or parallel
sentences they don't
know anything of that the only thing
they really need is
data lots and lots and lots of data
and given that a basic model and lots of
data they can
achieve outstanding performance in very
complex tasks
for instance they can do a supervised
machine translation
put into the correct architecture
a large amount of french a large amount
of german
you don't need to give it parallel
sentences translation dictionary they
can translate at a fairly high level
and this works so
observing that our idea is okay why why
can't we do the same for math after all
math is a language it might not be
the most natural of languages but it's a
language
and whereas in the past people have not
done that we thought that
actually having large data sets in math
is not a problem because you can
generate math
you can generate as many data as many
data set as you want
with well machines and finally we have
this idea that
after all digging a little deeper we
could consider that
math is similar to translation basically
solving a problem in math
is translating the problem into its
solution so it's a form of translation
from math to math but there's no real
difference
so this sort of sets the plan for the
paper
what we want to do is machine
translation for mathematics machine
transition applied to math
and there are several steps in this the
first one is that
if we want to use sectosec model we need
to adapt the math or to
bring the math to the models so we need
to represent the problems and the
solution of mathematical problems
as sequences that can be used by our
models
second we need to generate those large
sets of data i said it was possible but
it needs to be done and then we need to
train the model
and train them to say okay let's
translate the problem into the solution
and see if it works
so the first step we want to represent
problems and solution as sequences this
might seem
a big thing but actually it's relatively
easy because
we know that any expression mathematical
but also in language but also in
computer programming can represent can
be represented as a tree
how many names for those trees you know
in computer science you know
semantic tree symbolic tree past trees
it's always the same
you have a tree representing an
expression and this is actually the way
math is handled in computers when you
want to model the calculation
if that's the way you handle you know
compilation or any representation of
language
and math expression up just as i'm
enabled to this
free form as the rest of expression say
in computer science
so here's an example of three different
trees
in increasing degree of complexity the
first one
the leftmost is just a calculation two
plus three times five plus two
and you see how the tree is built every
internal node of the tree is an operator
plus
times plus the leaves of the tree are
the numbers
and the tree has this nice features that
it's
take cares of the order of operation
with a tree you don't need parenthesis
so it's even simpler
than the original expression going to
the central
uh tree i'm complexifying the thing a
bit so
i'm now taking care of a mathematical
expression it could be an equation if i
think it's equal 0 or an
equation if i say to add variables so x
it could be xyz
so i have a new kind of node
and then i i added two operator
a power operator which take care of a
square
and a cosine operator which is the case
of the cosine two x
and note that whereas all the operators
are binary the cosine operator is unary
that's one of the points the operators
are either unreal
binary the last expression is actually a
much more complicated version
it's um it's a differential partial
differential equation it's the
one-dimensional
wave function for those who have studied
physics
so it's something it's a more
complicated object in math
um you can imagine it as an equation by
adding equal zero at the end you don't
need to
add it to represent it in the machine
and
you see here i added a couple of new
letters greek letters
of sci fi new etc and i
added a new operator which is a
derivative the partial derivative
operator which is
a binary you derive something with
respect to something else
but what's interesting is that we
believe that a lot
probably most of the mathematical
expression that we can find
can be represented in that free form and
for anyone who has
some uh use habit of
computer science once you have a tree
it's very easy to imagine that you can
have a sentence
because we know how to enumerate trees
and to generate a sentence just by
reading the notes of the tree
in a certain predefinite order so in
this case we do pre-order or prefix
reading of trees which means that we
represent the trees as sequences
by first stating
the parent and then stating the left
node
the left child and then the right child
so for instance my left most three would
be
plus two times three plus
five two you see every time i'm
representing the top
node and then the left child and then
the right child and
going this way i get sentences sequences
for every
one of my three and i'm set
i got i can represent everything so you
see the process
i represent expression mathematical
expression as
trees and then the trees are sequences
and everything is ready whether it's the
problem a solution
is a material i can represent everything
in a form
that is interesting for my modeling my
further model
having done that we don't want to do
that on all of the master which shows
a certain number of subjects we want to
study and in this paper we
address three different problems of
mathematics
which is symbolic integration so
symbolic integration you know
integration is the reverse process of
derivation
uh so you have a function and you want
to know its integral
so that's the function which derivates
give the function you want
and then first order differential
equations which are
equations where you find a function that
verifies some relation
between the function and its first
derivative
and then second order differential which
is the same with the first and second
derivative
why do we choose those problems the
first thing is that they are very very
general and they're very
they have a lot of use in math and
especially in physics you know
derivatives
if you have a position in physics the
derivative of the position is the speed
the derivative the speed is
acceleration so this kind of
differential equation
sort of pop up everywhere in math and
physics everywhere
second good reason of taking that is
that those problems
are difficult problem they're very
involved problem
they're not the kind of thing that are
taught in elementary school etc you
usually start with them in university at
university level
and that's something which are
considered difficult for humans and
machines for humans they are difficult
you know a trained mathematician doesn't
solve a first or second order
differential equation like that it's
it's difficult it needs some work and
computers
do it and their algorithm not really for
symbolic integration one is known as
rich algorithm it's from the 70s
but it's a very complicated algorithm
one of the most complicated that exists
it is said that it takes more than 100
pages
of text to represent the pseudo code of
the rich algorithm and to my knowledge
even right now
no single mathematical
software implements it in full because
some parts of it are so complicated that
you cannot really efficiently implement
them
so those are tasks where both men and
machine
suffer they are close to the limit of
what we're able to do and what we're not
able to do
the last reason why we chose those tasks
is that
there are tasks where we believe that
natural language and translation system
might succeed for one reason i said in
the beginning that
neural nets are good at pattern
recognition and integration
is something about pattern recognition
you see in the in the function i have
here i see a sign
a sign x i know that if there's a sign x
in the in the function there will be a
cosine
in the integral somehow i know if that
if i have a square root somewhere i'll
see it in the integral in
some look so the idea is that
in general uh there's a good amount of
pattern recognition in the way
we humans solve symbolic integrals solve
first on second order differential
equation so this is exactly the kind of
difficult problems where
i would say deep learning or more
language models have a good chance
of succeeding
so now that we've presented the problem
and the models we use
um comes the second part it's about
generating the data sets so
we will need lots of examples to work um
lots means tens of millions we work from
between 20 and 50 million examples just
to train one model
um so we want to do supervised learning
you know
you've got several categories of way to
learn to train a network
we want to do supervised learning which
is a kind of learning when you have a
problem and a solution so you train the
model
with a problem to predict a solution and
you correct the model you improve it by
trying to reduce the discrepancy between
what the model predicted and the actual
solution you wanted to have
and you do this by calculating a
gradient back propagating it that's
the when you're on nets work so to do
supervised learning we need to create
very large data sets
of problems and solution we need both
so first we will need all the time to
generate random problems in solution
and at this point there's something
which is very nice which is the previous
the modeling widget we just did you know
with the trees and the sequences
also is a very helps us sampling
problems and solution you know if you
want to generate a random problem
or a random solution well since the
problem can be represented as a tree
you have to generate a random tree and
so you want to generate a random unary
binary tree
and then you will take all the nodes in
the tree and decorate them
so you will select at random um do
operators for the internal nodes and
leaves
the constants or variables for the
leaves and in this way
generating a random tree is relatively
easy
well we have the way to do it so the
paper goes at length explains especially
a lot about that because
of course generating a random tree is
not
um such a simple i mean
all the naive methods tend to fail
because they tend to generate
trees which are either very deep or
either very broad or
tend to lean left or right or center i
don't know but
you know having a really random three
structure for unary binary is
a complex thing so it's developed in the
so we provide an algorithm and a method
that that worked
and we also do a lot of calculation in
the appendix to explain
the size of the problem space to show
that the problem stress is absolutely
huge
so um this is important because um you
know people sometimes say oh
neural networks but they just memorize
the example the problem space here is so
large
that there's no chance that any network
or any machine
will ever memorize even a tiny part of
it
so we have a method to generate random
problems so how do we
generate problems and solution for
integration and
differential equation so for integration
the
most simple way to look at it which we
got the forward approach
is well you generate a random function
we've seen that this is possible
then that's the problem then you need to
compute the solution
uh so you compute the anti-derivative so
the integral
big f of the small f that you generated
and for that you need to use the
framework a symbolic framework symbol
mathematica something like that
and then you have a couple small f big f
problem solution which you add to the
training set rinse repeat 40 million
time and you're set
of course this seems a bit fishy uh
first you need an external symbolic
framework so it's not
it's not really elegant you need an
external tool second it's strange
because you want to solve a problem and
the first
step in solving the problem is to solve
40 millions of instances of
this problem so it's a bit yeah
you can do that in research but it's it
wouldn't work in the real world
um a more important problem is that
since you need an external
framework an external symbolic framework
simple mathematica all that
um only know to cannot
integrate all the functions you know
they have their limits
you are limited in your training sample
to the only function that the framework
can integrate
and this is a deep limit because it
means that the data you're training
is biased by the tool you use to produce
the data the symbolic framework you use
to produce the data
last point which is not negligible it's
very slow
uh on average a tool like simple
mathematica might take several seconds
to generate one
one solution one problem solution uh if
you want 50 million of examples you can
do the math even with a lot of computers
it's
uh it's a bit prohibitive so we want
we still generated such um such a sample
a small one but such a sample to to test
but we followed a different approach for
symbolic integration
which we call the backward approach
instead of generating a solution
a problem and finding a solution we
could generate a solution and find its
problem
and this turns out to be incredibly easy
for the
integration because it's in a way what
you could call a trapdoor
problem it's a problem that is very
difficult to solve one way
but which the reverse of it is very easy
to solve
what i mean by that is that suppose you
generate a random function but this time
the random function is the big f it's
the solution
it's the integral then the only thing
you need to find a problem is to
calculate the derivative which is a very
easy task you can do it in a symbolic
framework but you could even write the
code for it
so it's yeah a few hundred lines of code
it's not difficult to do in any case and
it works all the time and it's fast
and so when you do the backward approach
you can generate that very low cost
a large sample of problems in solution
but
is it exactly the same well actually if
you look at
what you get from the forward approach
you get this kind of problems and
solutions so those are functions
on the left and so those are the
problems
and those are the solution on the right
and you can see
okay these are the prominent solution
it's it looks good now look at what you
get with the backward approach
yeah you see forward backward backward
forward you see in the backward pro
approach you get very long problems with
very short solutions
in the forward approach you get short
problems and long solution and i chose
the examples but
this is true over the whole data set
um this is a limit of the way we
generate data
which approach is right none i mean the
function we get both function we want to
integrate
the short function that the short
function that have long integrals and
the long integrals that
long function that have short integrals
but uh
the thing is that since we generate long
problem with short solution we are not
working
exactly on the same kind of problem or
the same part of the problem space to be
more specific
than what we would do with the forward
approach
so question we had is could we mitigate
that
and for this we looked at the third
approach which is which is called
integration by parts integration by part
it's a trick
to calculate integrals normally which
takes advantage of the way
um products uh are derived
the way you calculate the derivative of
a product the idea is that it works like
a backward
generator so you don't need an external
to nothing
if you generate two random functions and
derive them
then you get two problems in solution as
before
but if in the past you happen to have
calculate small
f the the integral of small f
times big g then you have
the integral of big f times small g for
free and the other way around
it might look like a silly id but if you
have millions of
problems the number of cases where this
happens is much larger than one might
might be even and so you can generate a
very nice
new sample with that seeing like that it
seems like an unnecessary complication
but when you
look at the results of the integration
by part then it can you understand the
use
the thing is that the formula you see
above is
done in such a way that the left part so
what you're calculating is much
smaller than the right part and so you
will have that nice property that
forward generated samples had which were
short problem unknown solution it's not
as strong
as what you get in the forward example
but you could say that symbolic
integration by part sort of stands in
the middle between the backward forward
or something so we have three methods
to um generates all symbolic integrals
which will generate three different
samples well
i'll come back to that later um what do
we do for differential equation then
it's even worse because there's no
simple solution or automatic solution
for generating an ordinary difference
for solving an ordinary differential
equation
of a sufficiently general type um
formally i mean so what we do is that we
use a backward method
and here's the the general id so
the solution of first website the
solution of first order differential
equation are defined up to a constant c
so we write them up as a function of two
variable
y equal f of x the variable and see the
constant
and then we solve it we solve this
equation in c
so we pretend y is not a function it's
just a variable x is another variable
and we solve in c so we end up computing
a big
function big f that writes f x y equals
c
most of the time you can do this solving
analytically you lose a couple of
cases but not so many and the thing is
that once you have this function if you
differentiate it
then the right part being a constant
will come to zero
and the left part will be a very nice
differential equation of the first order
that's f source so i generated the
problem from my solution
to make this clear let me show you an
example so we have a random function
you see f at the top it's x times log c
on x i call that y solving it you can do
it for yourself i just invert so i say
c equals and this is my big f
then i can differentiate in x and i can
even simplify it
because you know the exponential in
front is a positive number so i can
remove it and i can move
avoid the division by x by multiplying
all the terms by x
and i end up with a very s nice and
simple
first order differential equation which
by no way one would guess
the solution as being the top one so
we're not helping the machine we're
generating pairs
that are not easy to guess you know you
can always generate pairs that are easy
to guess but
then then what's the what's the point
second so with this we can generate
ordinary differential equation and
we have a proof not in the paper but we
have sort of proven that
the the problems that we are generating
this way represents
um the large majority you know
everything except a measure
zero measure uh set of the set of
ordinary differential equation uh
satisfying
minimal condition of continuity of that
so
we're pretty pretty much so
working on all possible differential
equation with this system
we can expand this to the second order
we could actually expand it to
larger orders the thing is that you then
have two
integration constants and you will have
them two steps and two differentiations
so you start from a function f of x c
and d
you solve it in d so you get a big f
equals
x y t in d you then differentiate it so
you get
x y y prime c equals zero and then you
solve
again in c so you get the function of j
x x y y prime and you differentiate and
you get your solution so
it's a bit more involved but it's not
conceptually more difficult it's just a
little
more complicated to implement but
there's no real change
so having done that we built five data
sets so we have three data sets for
integration forward backward integration
by parts
our main data said the main training was
done on the backward sample
so we had 40 million problems on
solution we had smaller sets
of forward and back and integration by
partly because it was
much more slow to generate them
so we stopped a little earlier and we
have 40 million two for ode one or the
two uh what kind of functions do we work
with so we work with expression with up
to 15
internal modes of 15 operators in the
formulas so those are pretty big
formulas um the leave values are either
x there's only one variable
and integers between minus five and plus
five without zero
why the small integers because we don't
want to do arithmetic we know
the machine is not good at arithmetic so
it's not really useful
wasting time on you know having
complicated
calculation that the machine cannot do
we want to to be on a very basic system
so we keep
the integers small as for the operators
we use the four basic
operators plus minus times and divide
and 15 unary operators we have the
exponential and logarithm we have the
square roots we have the trig and the
inverse trig
and the hyperbolic trig and inverse
hyperbolic trig
those functions are known in the
mathematical literature about
integration as elementary function
they're basically
what people who study formal integration
usually do
it's very all theory that comes back to
youville and people in the 19th century
and this is the elementary function that
were used at this
at that time so not now that we're good
with the data sets we can go to the
training the models and looking at the
results this is the easier part actually
we've done the more advanced part of the
thing so for the model we're using
a transformer architecture i'm not going
to detail too much the
technique but the transformer is an
architecture of
a deep deep network that has becoming
incredibly positive
increasingly popular over the recent
years
it was usually mostly meant for natural
language but now it's used in
in many different cases a transformer
architecture is a
network which is non-recurrent you know
you have non-recurrent network
the feed forward networks where you have
one layer of neurons and the second and
the third
and so that and networks and every
network is every layer is connected to
the previous one
but there's there are no feedback
there's no connection backwards
so it goes from layer one to layer two
to layer three to the other 4 to layer 5
etc
recurrent networks on the other side so
rnn or lstm
have backward connection so
this means that they while you have
connection going up
from the input to the output but you
have also feedback loops inside they're
more difficult to train
the transformer is non-recurrent so you
don't have feedback loops but you have
a mechanism called attention which means
that
we're sort of having a transversal
connection
practically with the attention mechanism
what happens is that the output of a
neuron
in a particular layer depends on the
on the previous layer this is a hallmark
of every
fit for every neural nets but also on
the
on the on the output of the
neural on the neurons just before it's
on the same layer
so practically it sort of looks back
this is the attention mechanism
and this architecture has become
increasingly popular because this is
easy to train
it works extremely well on a very large
number of
cases apart from that the transformer
you use
is it's really run-of-the-mill
architecture and parameter
transformer so we use a fairly small
model
it's shallow it has only six layers it
has 512 dimensions which for transformer
is not very big
um it uses eight attention heads
attention heads at the the number of
cases where you look back at the same
layers and it's trained over a cross
entropy loss which is the loss you use
when you compare sequences you know it's
character is the same or difference and
stuff like that we use the adam
optimizer which is the
typical one used these days and batches
of 256
examples which are large batches which
sort of speed the training and also work
well so
keep in mind that it's it's a
transformer but it's a very standard
transformer and
in terms of speed and
greediness you know nlp models are known
for being
very using a lot of computing power this
actually runs on
one gpu a couple of cpu systems so it
doesn't
need a huge computing resource and we
train in
like a day maybe a day and a half but
that's that's pretty much it so
it's probably not something that can be
done on a very small
machine but it doesn't need a lot of
computing power to
to be trained um so that's
that's the training model at inference
we use something which is called as bin
search so in this systems
you generate the solution token by token
so you generate the most likely token
then given the first token you generate
the second one etc
and this is the way the model builds an
answer token by token
um this method allows for the generation
of several solutions this is what bing
search does
so instead of just generating the best
solution
you generate the two or three or ten
best solution and you go on
and you every time you limit the number
of solution you want to 10 or 50
but instead of generating one solution
you generate 1
10 50 several solution and this is what
beam search does
so why do we do that we do it so that it
it works with for evaluation how do we
evaluate the model
so the model uh the train model are
tested on held out samples
5000 samples which are built from the
same
generator as the data set so practically
when we generate our data sets we single
out 5000
examples that will be used for testing
and we check at that time
for the lack of overlap the absence of
overlap that which means that no
test problem has been seen during
training there are no
doubles no duplicates so
the held out examples are specific to
the test set and they don't belong to
the train set
then once we want to test we generate so
we feed the the problems into the model
the train model
it generates a solution and we check the
solution
and for checking the solution we use
simplify so we use an external tool to
check
because our models can have several
solutions and the solution in the test
set is not the only solution we don't
want to
say that it's wrong if we have a correct
solution which is not the one in the
test set
so we simply to check in the case of
integration it just means deriving the
solution
subtracting it for a problem instead
checking it's zero
for the ode you feed the equation
solution back into the equation and
check that
the result is zero it's relatively
simple
and then we use bin search to
try to improve our results if the first
solution proposed by the system is
incorrect
then we generate the second and the
third etc until we get
10 or 50 and until we find a correct one
so if we have in bim search one we say
the solution if correct if the first
guess
of the machine is correct if we
beam such 10 the machine is allowed 10
guesses
if it's 50 it's given 50 guesses okay
so that's the evaluation method so how
does this work so we trained the model
we evaluated it so what do we get
so in the table here you have five colon
one for each
data set and three lines for beam size
one
ten and fifty so the first three columns
are for the integration problem you can
see that for
all of them even in being side one you
are
well over 90 percent close to 95 and
sometimes
over of correct solution which means
that
at first its first guess the transformer
found the correct solution in 95 percent
of the 5
000 test set test example he had never
seen before
so that's that's a big success it goes
very well of course when you're already
on 95 the green size will help
but help very little even though it can
guess that's very very close to the 100
percent
very close to it you can see that
forward and integration by part achieve
slightly lower results i suspect is
because of the
sample size the data set size um
in practice on other experiments we
noticed that we were
quite similar what's interesting here is
that
of course we have very good results on
integration but what's more even more
important is that we have the same kind
of results
for forward backward and integration by
part
for the three data sets and this is
important because
when you work from generated data from
synthetic data there's always a doubt
and the doubt is when you get a result
is this result really due
to you know you having the model having
performed
or is it due to the data set because you
somehow generated
some you have some artifact in your data
which makes the data the problem you're
solving easier to solve or because
there's something with your data that
the model exploited which is not linked
to the problem
and this is always a problem with
synthetic data but
if like like here you manage to
get the same result on three totally
different data
generated with different ways then data
generation
is not a problem it's the sucks the
result
are the result of the model so it shows
that the method is to some extent
universal for differential equations
the problem is more difficult and gets
more difficult as order goes up
and you can see that the results go down
so being size 1 gets
from 95 96 for integration
to 78 and then 43 for differential
equation but this is where bim search
comes to the rescue
with the bim search we get back to 95 or
for both so results look pretty good how
good is this
so in order to compare we work on
state-of-the-art what's the state of the
art well
commercial programs like mathematica
that's all from
or matlab or marco mathematics much
better than the others so we must
we did on this problem on specific
problem so we mostly tested with
mathematica
what you can see is that on the backward
sample mathematica
achieves 84 of cases we are at 99
and on the lde it's closer on the od or
the one where equivalent mathematically
is even better than us
on all the other two but as soon as the
beam search sets in
then we are much better than mathematica
we will perform it
by a substantial margin it doesn't mean
this would happen on every single
equation we're on the
equation of our test set or backward
equation that we have
generated in this way and there are
cases where mathematics can solve
problems that we cannot solve and all
that
but still it's a very promising and
interesting result
so what we get at this point is
that's the basic result of the paper we
can train models
we can generate data set we can train a
transformer
and we manage to get results which are
relatively close
to state of the art to what mathematica
and others can
can do okay so
now i'd like to discuss a few
interesting cases and a few
let's have a few problems with this
approach of a few
questions that have been
have arisen and are interesting the main
question is generalization you know it's
every time you train and you use machine
learning there's someone at the end of
the
of the day of the conference that says
but how does your system generalize
and this is the real question you know
it's easy to train but does it
generalize
so for our system the first answer the
easy answer to that is yes it does
generalize because
all the test samples we use were not
seen at training so
the machine achieved those 99 percent of
those 80 percent on
on examples that it had never seen so in
this respect it does
generalize but this is a weak definition
of generalization there's a stronger one
because
thinking of it we're generating we're
working from generated data
and the training and test set come from
the same generator
what if they didn't actually if you
wanted to use such a system
in the wild in real integrals for
written
integrals or differential the the
integrals we have to solve would not
come from a generator that would come
from
whatever problem we're working on so
what if they don't come from the same
generator so there's a way an easy way
to test it
you know we have the forward and the
backward data
so on the table here you see in the line
you have the training data so the first
line was trained on forward the second
round was training
backward and the columns are the test
sets so
suppose that this instead of testing if
we test if we train on forward and test
on forward
you can see that's the first line first
column got the 95
person that we've seen before if we
train on backwards and test them
backward we're at this
the same results second nine second
column it's 99 percent all that but if
we train on forward and test on backward
then things get wrong very wrong without
17 percent at being 50
and train them backward and test it on
for what we are at 28.
these results no these results are
non-trivial you wouldn't get that with a
random machine so
the machine has clearly learned
something but it's extremely
disappointing
compared to the impressive results we
had before we are much much lower on
this case
so why is this and how damning is this
why is this the interpretation is
relatively easy
you remember backward models are long
problems with short solutions
forward problems forward models are
short problem with long solutions
so you remember the examples if i train
on the forward model
i've been training the model the my
model on examples
like this one and the model has learned
from the data
one of the basic laws of integration on
the
on the forward data which is integration
is an expander
it makes the solution longer than the
problem and the model is absolutely
certain about that because it's seen
here
it happened over 50 million of examples
and then you come a stat set and you
arrive with this which are the danding
exam the counter example
which the model hasn't seen during the
training of course it won't work and
saying the other way around why doesn't
it work because the model
has learned from the data different
properties of the training
to give an example of what this means
imagine you're training
an image recognition system to recogni
to recognize breeds of dogs
so you want to recognize you know
machines can do that so you show
lots of photographs of dogs and the
machine is supposed to classify them by
breeds
but suppose that's at the trainings time
all the samples all the dogs you show
are small dogs poodle dogs yorkshire
that kind of dogs dogs the size of cats
say
and suppose that at train at this time
you provide only pictures of big dogs
what do you think will happen the model
will fail is it the fault of the model
no it's the fault of the training data
the training data is incorrect
in this case it's more complicated
because we generated the data but
practically what we're saying is that if
you test
on data which is too different from the
training data
yeah it won't work is it really a
problem with generalization well
not completely um it's it's about
what could be said is that the backward
and forward
samples are exploring different problems
because they're exploring different
parts of the problem space can we
improve this
yes we can that's the whole point of the
integration by part
you remember we created the integration
by part as a real method that was on top
of the backward method
so those two graphs show the
distribution
of the number of tokens of the length of
the expression
for the derivative the problems and the
integral of the solution
and what you can see is that the
integration by parts
on the problems has exactly the same
distribution as the forward
data but on the solutions
the integration looks a lot like the
backward and is different from the
forward
this is a way to explain why the
integration backbone is sort of a middle
of the road example
it's in between so what happens now if
we train on forward or backward and test
on integration by part it's a different
sample so it's generalization
so look at the first line i just added
the column integration by part to the
right
what you see in the right well you can
see that the forward data
is very bad on the backboard but on the
integration by part i get 85 percent i
get the
very large values i had so i'm
almost as good on the integration by
part testing on integration like
the forward trend model as i was on the
forward test set
so the problem is corrected with a
backward trend model the integration bar
performs less well for some reasons
but still you can see that it's not just
a generation an outdoor domain
generalization problem because
you can see that you can generalize
correctly on different samples
provided this sample are not as removed
from the training samples as the forward
is from the backwards okay
and you can understand at this point how
we can emilio
improve the whole system because if i
train now on backward
plus integration by part i big i built a
big sample of the two
trainer on this then you can see that
when i test on forward that's the last
line of the first column the performance
increases a lot
it doubles so practically
we understand better now the
generalization problem the out-of-domain
generalization problem comes from the
fact
that different generators explore
different parts of the problem space
and that the result they get as they
explore different parts of the problem
space
will generalize to areas close to
those they have explored so it will
generate
a forward train model world generalized
to integration by part sample test
sample
but it will not generalize as far as
backward sampling
so what's the the solution then well the
solution is simple
if you want to have more generalization
you need
larger sample and you need more
generators you need more variety more
diversity
in your training data and if you have
mixed generators
in this case we cheat a bit because we
have backward integration by pattern
forward and we test them on the fridge
so
obviously we'll end up at 100 but still
if we have larger generators more
generated mixed into one training set
we improve the generalization so this is
the way
the problems of generalization should be
tackled
from this kind of model once we're on
generalization one nice
word which is more or less a fun fact
you remember the forward
data set in the forward data set i
generated a random
problem and i used a tool to generate a
solution the tool i used was senpai
which is a python symbolic calculator
the fun thing is that since senpai
provides me with a solution
my training set is only only contents
problems that simple can solve
then a test set i tried it on problem
that simply couldn't solve and you have
on the right a set of problems
that simply could not solve but the
train model trained on simpai could
solve
so in a way the model managed to
generalize beyond the generator the
student
uh be the master it's
it's more fun than something very
important because okay it just
shows that it generalized but it's
interesting to see that
generalization also goes this way
um the last thing i wanted to to show
was one of the more
mysterious part of the the research
we've done it's something we haven't
quite understood
it's about the beam search you remember
the beam search instead of generating
just one solution a gen
generator collection and so far the way
i use bin search was
it was a way to cheat or to improve my
solution by
allowing my machine to have several
guesses
so if the first guess was wrong i use
the beam for the second a third etc and
improve the
result but what happens if the first
guest is correct
so here's an example from differential
equations so at the top you have the
differential equation we
used so you see it's a big differential
equation
and below you have 10 solutions which
are the 10 solutions that were in the
beam
together with a score which is a log
probability
of the likeliness how how good the model
considered they are
you can see that the 10 solutions look a
bit like well actually they're more than
that the first solution is correct but
the nine others are two they're all
correct solution to the same problem
but they're different some of them have
different values of the constant
some of them are different ways to write
the same thing some of them are even
unsimplified if you look on the first
column the third one there's a square
root two and a two
that should be simplified but the model
didn't
it doesn't care about simplification so
you provide another one
the fun thing is that the beam contents
different possible solution to the same
problem
and this is interesting because our
problem have many solutions because of
integration constant but also because
solution can be written in different
ways
and those equivalent solution can still
be retrieved from the beam
which seemed that the machine has
learned something it wasn't taught
what is what are two equivalent
solutions
and i'm saying this is mysterious and
quite
thought provoking because whereas up to
now what we have learned were
more or less pattern recognition so we
try to guess that when you see a sign
the interval is a cosine
and all that's this property that's
values that these different formulas
correspond to the same mathematical
object
are not properties pattern recognition
properties they're real mathematical
properties it has to do with the meaning
of the symbols
and this is one one of the things we
haven't taught the model so the model
somehow learned something about
mathematics i'm not saying it's
it's like everything but it learns
something just from example
and without any prior teaching or
education say in basic mathematics
this is also an important problem
because this equivalent problem
is what we do most of the time when we
do standard mathematics you know when
you transform a
solution into when you transform an
equation
you're doing equivalency when you
factorize you do one when you simplify
you do one
so having models learn this kind of
property is having them learn some kind
of a very
fundament something of a very
fundamental nature
so it's very interesting so i'm at the
end of the presentation so to summarize
a few takeaways
um so the first conclusion is that
machine translation
models can be used in mathematics we've
shown how they can be used in
integration they can be used in other
directions
you can do math with a deep learning
network if you do it well
the important thing is data generation
the only way you can train a model is to
have lots of data and
to have so much data you need to
generate it and data generation is
doubly important because not only the
key to training it's also the key to
generalization if you want to have good
generalization
then you need to generate diversity by
having different generators
work together the last point
which i just mentioned is that
equivalence so the fact that something
some different expression can represent
the same mathematical object
might at some point time be learned for
free
so that was all the presentation uh
as for reference we are we've got a
paper on archive
and all the code and
examples and samples can be found on the
facebook research github
thank you for your attention
thank you for the presentation uh this
is wonderful
it's very it's very interesting that you
are able to take
a sort of collection of standard
problems and discover a lot about
how machine learning really works and
you know i
commend you for your choices i think
it's uh
it's probably eventually going to evolve
into a very useful tool as well
[Music]
thank you very much